the biden white house is calling on big
tech companies
to censor conservatives for spreading
misinformation
online specifically when that
information
has to do with the wu flu and its
attendant vaccines here is jen
saki explaining the policy first it
shouldn't come as any surprise that
we're in regular touch with social media
platforms just like we're in regular
touch with all of you
and your media outlets about areas where
we have concern information that might
be useful
information that may or may not be
interesting to your viewers you all make
decisions just like the social media
platforms
make decisions even though they're a
private sector company and different but
just as an example
so we are regularly making sure social
media platforms are aware
of the latest narratives dangerous to
public health
that we and many other americans seeing
are seeing across
all of social and traditional media and
we work to engage with them to better
understand the enforcement of social
media platform policies as you all know
information travels quite quickly
if it's up there for days and days and
days when people see it
you know there's it's hard to put that
back in a box
okay it's hard to put it back in the box
that's why the big tech companies need
me to censor these conservatives
spreading the misinformation except
that new evidence surrounding the virus
and the vaccines show
that joe biden kamala harris and the
rest of the liberal establishment
have been spreading far more
misinformation than the right has
whatsoever so we will
inform you we will give you the true
information so long as the real
misinformers don't stop us
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment friday from michael larson
who says does anyone else see the irony
behind the statement
that biden wants to slow the spread of
misinformation
how long will that take 15 days well if
it takes 15 days it'll probably take 15
months or maybe even 15 years
a very good point it's so exhausting
those 15 days
to slow the spread which is why i'm so
happy that i can rest my head
on my pillow you know how much i love my
pillow
a lot of conservatives love my pillow
because they're a good patriotic company
that shares our politics
let me tell you something if my pillow
were run by the chinese communist party
i would still support it because the
products are just that great so i love
my pillow and i love the new giza dream
bed sheets made from the world's
softest cotton called giza i'm decked
out with all the my pillow
products the geezer dream bed sheets
come in a variety of sizes and colors
and my pillow has a special offer for my
listeners you will
receive two for one low price plus
free shipping go to mypillow.com click
on the radio listeners square and use
promo code
daily wire there you will find not only
this phenomenal offer but also deep
discounts on all
my pillow products including the my
pillow mattress top or my pillow towel
sets
and so much more if you don't want to go
online you can call 1-800-951-7163 use
promo code dailywire
or you can just go online mypillow.com
promo code dailywire you will thank me
later i want to get to the
misinformation that joe biden and kamala
harris and the rest of them have been
spreading for over a year now
but before we get into that before we
get into
biden making the case that he himself
should be censored on social media
i i have to point out that biden is also
making the case
for president trump's lawsuit against
the big tech company so we covered this
a few weeks ago
donald trump is suing big tech companies
along with a few other social media
influencers
including my friend flekus from fleckest
talks who i saw last night actually here
in tampa florida a story we'll get to
also in just a moment but trump along
with some social media influencers
suing big tech for the violation of
their first amendment rights
and a lot of geniuses have said that
trump's lawsuit
has absolutely no merit because facebook
is a private business
as jinsaki just tried to say i said look
facebook is a private business
so facebook can do what it wants but
we are pressuring them to silence our
political
opponents and this gets to a legal
framework
under which trump's lawsuit could be
successful that coincidentally we laid
out on
my podcast with senator cruz verdict
some weeks ago
so senator cruz made this point he's the
legal expert not me
but we put it out there on verdict and
the point is this
yes a private business can censor you
generally speaking if it wants to
and that's not a first amendment issue
unless the government
is using that private business as a
proxy
to silence you so if it is the case
that the liberal establishment the
democratic party the government is
using facebook twitter youtube google as
a proxy to silence their political
opponents then it actually is a first
amendment issue
there are other problems by the way with
private companies censoring you online
that do not have to do with the first
amendment but that's that's the way that
would work and trump decided to take the
first amendment route
well joe biden and jen saki are
admitting that he's got a point because
they are now admit i don't know what
they're thinking
other than they're just letting it it
slip because it's convenient to their
other political narratives
because it's it's assuaging a leftist
base that wants the government to
pressure
facebook more to censor conservatives
but they are admitting that they are
using facebook
as a proxy here so giving a lot of merit
i think to donald trump's
lawsuit against big tech now
even even more ironic while they're
complaining about misinformation online
about the virus and about the vaccine
they seem to forget
that they themselves have been spreading
the anti-vaccine
hysteria alarmism that they're accusing
their opponents of pushing
please roll the tape let's just say
there's a vaccine
that is approved and even distributed
before the election
would you get it well i think that's
going to be an issue for all of us
if and when the vaccine comes it's not
likely to go through all the tests that
needs to be ended trials that are needed
to be done
when we finally do god willing get a
vaccine
who's going to take the shot who's going
to take the shot
you can be the first one to say put me
sign me up
they now say it's okay and the question
of whether it's real when it's there
that requires enormous transparency you
got to make all of it available to other
experts across the nation
so they can look and see so there's
consensus this
is a safe vaccine if the president
announced tomorrow we have a vaccine
would you take it
only if it was completely transparent
that other experts
in the country could look at it only if
we knew all of what went into it if
donald trump can't give answers and
administration can't give answers to
these three questions
the american people should not have
confidence but if donald trump tells us
i should
that we should take it i'm not taking it
wow
i had no idea that there was such broad
agreement between me
and joe biden and kamala harris not on
the trump digs
but on the vaccine a vaccine comes out
tomorrow
who's going to take it are you going to
take it you're going to be the first one
no
probably i wouldn't want to be the first
one to i get why a lot of people don't
want to take the vaccine
because it was rushed through because
it received an emergency use
authorization but it didn't go through
the normal
channels to clear the vaccine and
because of many other factors too namely
the prudential judgment am i really at a
huge risk from the coronavirus if you're
in
certain demographics if you're a young
person if you're otherwise healthy then
you're not at very great risk
so maybe you wouldn't want to take the
experimental drug that both kamala
harris and joe biden
pointed out we have plenty of reason to
to think might not be safe
base but they get to remain on social
media and a lot of conservatives who
raise questions about the vaccine
do not because of course
it's not about the vaccine it's not
about the quality of the information it
is about who's
giving the information it's about who's
sending the message
like political correctness like so much
of the left's control over speech
the issue is not the substance of the
speech it's the
imposition itself who gets
to say it by their look i don't
what joe biden and kamala harris just
said i don't think that's misinformation
they're they're just explaining the
natural plain fact that when an
experimental drug comes out a lot of
people are going to be reticent
to take it especially if the virus that
it's supposed to stop
is not all that great a danger to them
so i don't think that's misinformation
but by
their own standards that is
misinformation and they should be kicked
off the internet and they won't
because this entire campaign
for fact checking in the sense and the
content
filters and the do you want to read this
article before you tweet it
and the not even being able to privately
message certain articles critical of the
the liberal regime that whole thing is
just a political tool
for the suppression of their political
opponents
also by the way at this very moment
right now
we are being told by public health
officials that the vaccine
is basically useless now they're not
using
those exact words but when you look at
my
old old state of california run by mr
nussolini
if you look at my old city of los
angeles also known as gamora by the sea
they are reinstituting a mask mandate
well okay
i guess we've been hearing now from
liberal scaremongers that we still have
a raging epidemic
especially among the unvaccinated so
okay i guess it makes sense that the
unvaccinated need to wear the masks even
oh wait a minute no
everybody needs to wear the masks now as
of saturday night
everybody in los angeles including
vaccinated people
needs to wear masks indoors because i
guess the vaccines aren't working
if the vaccines were working vaccinated
people would not need to wear the masks
but i guess the vaccines are not working
but it's still very urgent that you take
the vaccine to fight against the virus
which is the worst epidemic
that we've ever faced but it's not so
terrible that you've got to shudder
i don't know marijuana dispensaries it's
not so terrible that you've got to
shudder
casinos it's not so it's but you do have
to shudder churches and you do have to
shatter businesses and the whole thing
just seems a little bit like an
arbitrary use of power
whole thing seems like a lot of
misinformation going around here
you know i'm very glad to be in florida
right now i'm very glad
not to be in
los angeles i'm very glad not to be in
california these places that are really
locked down i'm in florida
for tpusa i'm going to be giving a
speech this afternoon
4 20 or so eastern time very excited
about there have been some real
rock stars here rhonda santa spoke
yesterday ted cruz spoke yesterday
we got a bunch of great people coming
out today
and and of course tp usa was trending it
always is trending because the left
finds something to make a big deal of
that and this time
the issue was here's the headline let me
tell you the headline
porn star featured as vip
at tpusa student conference i saw that
that was the trend yesterday on twitter
i said oh my gosh they got a porn star
speaking at
at tp usa so i looked that was not the
case
as always i don't believe the headline
is all whenever you see the headline
charlay kirk is doing this terrible
i said no i don't i don't think that's
true so i looked and
what happened was a porn star decided to
attend the conference and she bought her
own vip ticket
and she was just showing up to listen to
the speakers
and this created two reactions on the
right
both of which i think were wrong so
there was the very wrong reaction
which was hey porn is great
if that's true freedom we need to be the
cool party
we need to endorse porn and drugs and
stuff and that's awesome and that's
gonna be the party of the future
yeah and porn's nothing more american
than apple pie okay
so that's obviously a ridiculous
libertine point of view
then there was the more conservative
point of view
which is this is you know terrible this
is awful
there was a lot of invective sent
against this porn lady
people calling her all sorts of terrible
names and saying she needs to be shunned
from society and
shouldn't show her face anywhere and i
think that reaction was a little
a little off as well i think there
actually was a
third way here that the conservatives
should have pursued
and it's this had this porn lady been a
speaker
had this porn lady had a booth to do
what we don't know at the conference had
this porn lady been making a big
nuisance of herself and making a big
show of herself
and trying to become a leader or a
speaker or a focus of a conservative
summit
that would be a very bad thing and
obviously she should have been
kicked off of the premises but as far as
i can tell that's not what happened
as far as i can tell this porn lady
showed up she was she used her christian
name she didn't use her porn names and
no one
even who would have heard of her had had
seen anything
and she was just kind of minding her own
business and watching the conservative
speakers
isn't that good if she's if she's just
totally minding her own business
she's not trying to recruit anybody for
her
pornography business isn't that good
don't we want that to happen i just
i felt that the invective sent against
this woman
was really misplaced because i got to
tell you
something tells me that if you work in
pornography if you're a prostitute or a
porn actress
you probably don't have the strongest
sense of self-dignity
you probably don't have the strongest
feelings of self-worth
and to be called all sorts of names and
to be told that you're the
root of all evil in society i don't
think that's very nice i don't think
it's nice to
speak in a harsh vulgar way to women
ever whether it's a prostitute or a
princess i don't think that's right
and i also just think if this woman
she's still working in pornography but
she's clearly interested by some
conservative arguments
and maybe she's only right now gone
through like the shallow conservative
arguments
but she's obviously interested if i can
get her into a room
where she hears conservative speakers
where she hears me give a speech
about how porn is bad and you shouldn't
be in the industry and if you're in it
you should get out
and if you're supporting it you should
stop supporting it and if you
are a legislator you should restrict it
or even ban it outright
if she can hear those arguments and
maybe be persuaded
i think that would be a good thing i i
know that when
conservatives call for a big tent party
99 times out of 100 what that means is
they want to just get rid of all of our
standards
and they want to just become democrats
light if if light or just
identical to the democratic party and
not have any boundaries at all i know
that's how that works
a lot of the time but the good version
of a big tent party
is we have these standards we hate porn
among other things you can't do that
there's no spot for that in the
conservative movement
but there is a spot for you if you want
to get out of it
this is look obviously i've been
talking about speechless for a very long
time which is available now for order
i don't think there is anybody in the
conservative movement who has been more
vocal about the need for standards about
the need to suppress
vice about the need to stop saying that
you can just say and do whatever you
want all the time okay
we certainly need standards but the
point of standards is not to kick
everybody out
the point of standards is not to be
insular and small and exclusive
or exclusionary the point of standards
is to bring
as many people as possible along to hold
themselves
to a higher standard of speech and
conduct and so i just
i'm obviously much more sympathetic to
the point of view
that you know these porn stars need to
be cast into outer darkness where
there's wailing and gnashing of teeth
but that actually isn't my view
my view is that porn needs to be cast
into the outer darkness and the people
who are caught up in the industry
especially the women who
generally don't come from great
backgrounds and haven't had a great life
they need to be welcomed in and
they need to be given the arguments as
to why this is terrible
and they need i think it would be good
to elevate their their political views
and and so i just think the invective
the meanness that
we we got to ditch that sort of thing
and and really you use standards for
their true purpose
which is elevating individuals and
elevating society
speaking of bringing lots of people in
you know speaking of the the big tent
the the big tent of our country has
really gone quite wrong
i think that the the way this applies at
the national level
has uh speaks to the idea that there are
no boundaries and there are no borders
and there's really not even much of a
country because we've got
lots and lots of people pouring into
this country from other nations
they have been told by people at the
highest levels of government
that they can stay and it's no big deal
and don't worry about it
for instance daca this was barack
obama's
one of his signature achievements where
he just gave
executive amnesty to lots and lots of
what we were told were very
young illegal alien children turns out
they're like 40 years old right
it's people who are in the middle age
and younger who came here when they were
minors
they were given executive amnesty well
there's some good news here which is a
judge has come in
a federal judge andrew s haynen of the
u.s district court in houston
who is a george w bush appointee he came
in and said that the executive
order for daca was unlawful
that obama exceeded his authority when
he issued it
he's saying that the executive order
violated the administrative procedure
act
because it failed to allow public
comments so great oh this is good i'm
glad
daca it's illegal big victory for
conservatives right
no it's not no it's i mean i'm glad that
the judge is admitting that
it was wrong for obama to do what he did
but the simple fact is obama succeeded
at doing it
he gave the illegal aliens the
protection to stay here
and we can't just take that back because
some judge ordered it it just won't
happen
we already knew that daca was illegal
barack obama
already admitted that that daca was not
just illegal but unconstitutional
obama said in october 2010
quote i am not a king i can't do these
things
just by myself in march of 2011 barack
obama
said that quote with respect to the
notion that i can just
suspend deportations through executive
order that's just not the case
and then in may of that year he said
that he couldn't quote just
bypass congress and change the
immigration law myself
that's not how a democracy works and
then what did obama do
he did that he just did it and we all
rent our garments and nashed our teeth
but he he won
he got it no judge is going to undo that
and this is a problem with illegal
immigration generally
you're not going to get mass
deportations
it's just not going to happen because
it's politically untenable if anyone was
going to do it it was going to be donald
trump
and he didn't he didn't do it and now
you you actually did see at the
beginning of the trump presidency you
saw a big dip in illegal immigration
when they thought that he could enforce
the law and he wanted to enforce the law
but he was stymied by the bureaucracy
and then
illegal immigration jumped up again now
we have reached
record left truly record levels of
illegal immigration much higher
than anybody seems to know about
and nothing's going to happen which is
which is why there's no substitute for
victory folks
i think a lot of people believe okay
we'll let the illegal
aliens in now okay we'll deal with
executive amnesty now and we'll fix it
later
some things really can't be fixed later
because
you've already you've already messed it
up
once an illegal alien comes into this
country
it is virtually impossible to deport
that person
as a legal matter as a political matter
we have to secure the border
at the border you can't do it after the
fact there's not
time to do all we we actually have to
stand up and win the victories losing
with dignity is not an option you can't
correct that later
you've got to win
you know speaking of winning i think the
daily wire is really winning right now
because
they've got a new show coming in that
would be the morning wire if the
american people have an enemy you know
what that enemy would be it would be the
establishment media
which uses its platform to lie and lie
and spin and spin and they
they do it all not just on their opinion
programming but on their alleged news
program
they have their really soft voice and
welcome this is the daily morning news
show i'm
i and here are the facts and the fact is
donald trump is a terrible fascist and
you're all racist white supremacist
that's just the facts
but that because they sound like really
smooth about it you know people believe
it
and and bourgeois housewives in the
middle of the country believe it too so
we gotta stop that all right and daily
wire is leading the fight
we have got our new morning news show
it's it's
short it's packed full of the facts it's
going to come out every morning it's
hosted by daily wire editor-in-chief
john bickley
and co-host georgia howe uh great
friends of mine
great talents it's called morning wire
go subscribe today you can subscribe on
apple podcast spotify google play
stitcher
wherever you get your spot your wherever
you spotify that would be on spotify
wherever you get your podcasts please
leave a five star review
and help us take down the establishment
press
also please uh pre-order
ben shapiro's new book right after you
order my book speechless please
pre-order
ben's new book the authoritarian moment
which will double of course as a
campaign sticker when i run for office
so you can
you have the book you can read it and
enjoy it then you can cut out the cover
and say knowles 2028 the authoritarian
moment we'll be right back with a lot
more
188 000 illegal aliens
entered our country in june last month
188 000 not
entered our country this year i think a
lot of people think the number would
probably be
you know this year six months in maybe
we've had 188 000 no no
we have officially surpassed one million
migrant encounters this year we are on
track for
two million by the end of the year
this is record shattering numbers way
higher than anybody thinks
poll after poll shows that the american
people want to drastically reduce not
just illegal
but legal immigration if we've got two
million illegal aliens pouring into the
country this year we've got another one
to two million
legal aliens that is an untenable number
folks
over the last 60 years the migration
into the united states is the largest
movement
of human beings ever in recorded history
all while we are being told that we
cannot encourage assimilation
all while we are being told that our
country's evil and terrible and rotten
if it's so
ill evil and terrible and rotten where
are three to four million people coming
here every year
that's you can't even under the best of
circumstances you can't assimilate that
many people
but certainly not under these
circumstances
this is this is what you might call a
hostile takeover i'm not even saying by
the illegal aliens themselves
i'm saying by the leftist radicals and
liberal elites
who are using the immigration issue as a
way to radically
transform our country and make no
mistake that's what they're doing
they've given us a new american flag no
longer the stars and stripes it's the
rainbow
actually it's the new one with the
rainbow and the racial stuff in a
triangle it's called the progress flag
it's
very strange we've got a new national
independence day used to be the fourth
of july now it's juneteenth
the juneteenth national independence day
holiday we used to have the 1776
founding of our country
now it's the 1619 founding it's a new
country
that they're trying to push on us and
some of the radical leaders are not
really hiding it
the head of one of the naacp chapters
was just caught on camera
saying that if you are a parent
who protests critical race theory in the
schools who protests the sort of
anti-american ideologies that are
tearing down our country
but you should just die
and remain steadfast steadfast in
speaking truth
tearing down double standards and a
beauty double talk let's not
allow any double downing on live
let's prepare our children for a world
they deserve let's deny this off-key
band of people
that are anti-education energy teacher
anti-equity anti-history anti-racial
reckoning
anti-opportunities and to help people
into diversity
anti-platform anti-science interchange
agent anti-social justice
anti-health care anti-worker anti-lgbtq
plus
anti-children anti-health care
anti-worker
anti-environment anti-admissions policy
change
anti-inclusion anti-live and let live
people
let them die don't that leave
uncomfortable people deter
us from our old march forward
let them die so on the one hand
this i think this is a threat because
we have heard especially from blm and
antifa and we've seen especially from
blm and antifa and other
leftist radical groups the use of
political violence the use of terrorism
the use of violence against civilians to
achieve
a political end we've seen that a lot
over the past year so i do think this is
a threat
but it's not just a threat it's actually
even more insidious than a threat
it is the explanation of what the left
means by progress it isn't a vowel of
belief
in progress with a capital p is what
what this woman is saying is
we radicals are going to win we are
going to transform this country we are
going to
fundamentally invert this country and
it's just going to happen
that's the arc of the moral universe
it's long but it bends toward
justice that's what progress is and so
if we just wait them out they will die
and that'll be a good thing
and then we can move on now
it's worth noting what she's saying here
because sometimes you'll hear
people on the right talking about
replacement migration
or this idea that the traditional
american demographic makeup is going to
be radically transformed and this is
part of a political agenda
and that belief is called white
supremacist and
nazi and fascist and you know all the
things that they call every other thing
that uh so anyone to the right of
hillary clinton believes
but what this woman is saying is that
right she she is giving credence to that
theory she's saying yeah let them die
whether it's the evil straight white men
whether it's the terrible conservatives
more broadly
you let them die they're going to die
out and they're going to be replaced
by good radicals of this wonderful new
coalition that we're putting together
you've there have been other prominent
leftists to have said this and then
even in the washington post and in other
major major
outlets of the legacy media you will see
them come out very often and say
ha ha this terrible straight white men
are about to
be supplanted as a big portion of the
population so they give credence to this
theory too
and i don't think that they would refer
to themselves as nazis and white
supremacists
and so forth but they believe that that
is part and parcel
of progress and and they're obviously
willing to engage in acts of violence to
do so
they not only say it in speeches like
this but they actually have committed it
during for instance the blm riots and
speaking of acts of violence
what one thing the left has done very
well is they've redefined perfectly
innocuous
speech acts as acts of violence and
they've redefined violence as speech
and and it's been largely successful
well the american booksellers
association
has joined the bandwagon the american
booksellers association
is a 121 year old trade organization
for booksellers they mentioned in one of
their mailers
a very popular book by my friend abigail
schreier a book that i actually blurbed
it's called irreversible damage and it's
about how
young girls are being seduced into the
transgender
nonsense and are having great regrets
because of this and are mutilating their
bodies for
for no reason very important book
it was banned from target i think and
from some other book stores but it's
still sold very very well
the aba mentions this very popular book
and they received huge backlash so they
sent out a statement saying quote
an anti-trans book was included in our
july mailing
to members this is a serious violent
incident that goes against aba's ends
policies values and everything we
believe and support
it is inexcusable pause right there
goes against everything you believe in
so you're you're telling me
american book sellers association that
everything you believe
is that we should mutilate little girls
to make them look more like little boys
that is everything you don't believe
that
two plus two equals four you don't
believe that uh the sun shines during
the daytime
you believe that the sum total of your
belief
is that we should mutilate little girls
i don't know if i buy that
this is a violent incident no a violent
incident is when you mutilate little
girls
because of your sick heresy that your
body has nothing to do with who you
really are that's a violent incident
mentioning a book that reports on that
is not
violence that's journalism and
it's journalism actually that aims at
reducing violence they go on
we apologize to our trans members into
the trans community for this terrible
incident and the pain we caused them
we apologize to the lgbtqia
plus every day there's one more letter
community at large and to our book
selling community apologies are not
enough
we've begun addressing this today and
are committed to engaging in the
critical dialogue
needed to inform concrete steps to
address the harm that we caused
those steps will be shared in the next
three weeks so just notice this language
harm
violence this is all part of the same
thing that biden and gensake are talking
about
they are redefining innocuous speech
acts
as violence and they are
then going to try to ban that sort of
speech and they're going to try to ban
it
on social media say and what we are
going to be told is these are private
entities but they're not private
entities
they are first of all by definition
public if they're controlling the flow
of
information around the public square in
a republic but moreover
they're they're working very often at
the behest of the government as biden
and gensake
are proving and conservatives we need to
be very careful
in our language here because there are
some narrow types of speech
that do constitute an act of violence if
you engage in a direct
threat that is not protected speech
that is assault actually right that is
already defined as an act of violence
if you engage in certain fraud these
sorts of things
you could make an argument that that is
in itself causing harm and that is an
act of violence
and so i think we need to be very
specific here what abigail schreier is
doing
is engaging in not only innocuous speech
but actually speech
that is good and speech that is aimed at
reducing violence
and in this upside down world that we're
all living in now that is being
redefined as violence and violence is
being defined as peaceable and innocuous
we need to get even more specific than
the traditional and i think very useful
idea that speech is not violence and
violence is not speech we need to get
even more specific now
because the left is not only clearly
interested in redefining these things
but they have the political power to do
it they're being pretty
pretty uh successful now speaking of
acts of violence
right now in cuba there is a mass
protest movement going on
people are going out and protesting the
cuban communist dictatorship
and the government is clamping down the
president or the dictator rather of cuba
has come out and said they will do
anything they can to preserve the regime
up to and including using violence on
the citizens which they're currently
doing right now
they're naming people beating people and
actually killing people in the streets
and those crickets that you hear right
now are from bernie sanders
because bernie sanders who very nearly
was the democrat nominee for president
twice in 2016
and 2020 long time democratic senator
very long time gadfly he's been in
politics for 50 years
bernie sanders has spoken in very
positive ways
about the cuban dictatorship what i said
is what barack obama said in terms of
cuba
that cuba made progress on education
yes i think really
really do i support their economic
policies
or their political policies of course i
don't but you know what else
cuba produces a lot of physicians in
this country
and you know where they go they go to
poor countries around the world
doing a lot of good by and large cuba's
educational system
for a poor country is pretty good when
castro came to power
they did a lot to eliminate illiteracy
in that country
but i remember for some reason i was
being very excited when when fidel
castro made the revolution in cuba and i
was a kid and i remember reading that
and it was just seemed right and
appropriate that poor people were rising
up against
rather ugly rich people i was watching
the debates you remember the famous
nixon
kennedy debates that was the first time
the presidential camp candidates
actually debated
kennedy was saying that nixon was too
soft on communism
usually i'm sufficiently unemotional not
to be sick but i actually got off in the
room
and almost left the puke he almost left
to puke he was so upset
because bernie sanders has supported
communism
in those terms right the guy honeymooned
in the soviet union it doesn't
doesn't get more supportive than that
and now what we're seeing
is the people of cuba long oppressed by
an
evil evil system of government rising up
against that
and bernie has nothing to say he has
nothing to say
because he obviously does not speak for
the cuban people he obviously does not
speak
for the oppressed masses i mean this is
the problem that the marxist
revolutionaries had going back to the
days of karl marx
namely that they had all these wonderful
theories for the liberation of the
oppressed masses
but the allegedly oppressed masses
didn't like the theories very much
turned out that the oppressed masses
actually liked their own traditions and
their own countries
and their own families and rituals they
didn't like
the crazy radicalism this is what you're
seeing
right now with marxists in our
valid marxists in our schools and in
other institutions
and you're seeing the actual oppressed
masses in america coming out and
protesting and saying i don't want my
kids being taught this stuff
you're seeing black mothers white
mothers hispanic mothers showing up to
the school board saying
look we don't have a ton of money to
send our kids to private school we don't
have a ton of time to homeschool
we've got to send our kids to these
public schools and you nut
nut bags are coming in and saying that
we've got to
teach our kids critical race theory or
teach our kids critical gender or
radical gender theory and the elites are
saying well no these
these are actually wonderful ideologies
for you they're going to liberate you
they're going to help you
calm down you oppressed masses you just
don't get how wonderful this is
that's what bernie's done on cuba now
for 50 years
and it turns out doesn't work out very
well so he can't he's not going to
continue to defend it right now
he's just got to remain totally silent
as the biden white house by the way has
done until
just recently
jensaki jensaki has a very difficult job
and she's been under fire a lot lately
because
while cubans in the streets are
protesting the dictatorship
she refuses to call out communism she
has been asked well
can you acknowledge this is about the
communist dictatorship
and she says well it's about you know
economic mismanagement
and coveted vaccines can't you hear them
i know it sounds like they're chanting
libertad
but they actually are saying no uh covid
vaccinos
muy covid vaccine can't you hear that no
that's not i don't think that's what
they're saying so finally
she's faced so much pressure from this
she had to acknowledge that this comes
down to the failed ideology
of communism does this white house still
think
the protests in cuba are happening
because people are upset about a rise in
coveted cases there or is there some
thought maybe given to the possibility
that they are protesting because they
are sick of communism
well peter first i would say communism
is a failed
ideology and we certainly believe that
it has failed the people of cuba
they deserve freedom they deserve a
government that supports them
whether that is making sure they have
health and medical
supplies access to vaccines or whether
they have
economic opportunity and prosperity and
instead this has been a government an
authoritarian
communist regime that has repressed its
people
and has failed uh the people of cuba
hence we're seeing them in the streets
but i would note that
the ideology of the government which has
failed
has led to a fail a lack of access to
economic opportunity to medical
supplies to covet vaccines so all of
those pieces are true
good good it only took her two weeks to
say communism is bad
not because i think gensake or joe biden
are communists
but because a lot of the base is
a lot of the real interest groups on the
left that have a lot of influence
are avowedly marxist i mean blm for
instance
says that itself the blm's founders say
they are trained marxists and they've
spoken very highly of marxist leaders
but the problem is not just marxism the
the influence of communism
on the american left is a problem it's
been a problem going back over 100 years
now
but there's a further problem within
this regime
of what you might call managerialism the
liberal establishment
that that's a problem too that
that is a problem of a overwhelmingly
managed economy where the government
exerts a lot of influence on allegedly
private corporations and the private
corporations do the bidding
of the dominant liberal regime and they
suppress political dissent
and they won't allow you to raise any
concerns about for instance gensake
vaccines and coronavirus and the
misinformation that's been coming
out of the regime itself there are some
similarities here
while communism is a big problem it's
not the only failed ideology in the
world
and i think we've got to recognize that
there are some other problems going on
here and it's not it's not exclusively
the commies hiding under the beds
but there are also issues with
neoliberalism there are also
issues with managerialism there are also
issues
with the misinformation in our own
regime speaking of failed communist
regimes or rather repressive communist
regimes that are
maintaining themselves in power very
well the chinese communists it turns out
lied about the coronavirus and even the
biden officials are willing to admit
this now senior biden officials
according to cnn even according to
pravda for the regime
quote senior biden administration
officials overseeing an intelligence
review into the origins of the
coronavirus
now believe the theory that the virus
accidentally escaped from a lab in wuhan
is at least as credible as the
possibility that it emerged naturally in
the wild
a dramatic shift from a year ago when
democrats publicly downplayed the
so-called labley clearing
gee you don't say the the bat
coronavirus that we've never seen before
happened that happened to be discovered
right near that lab that works on back
coronaviruses
they might have had something to do with
each other oh wow gosh
amazing experts thanks for admitting
that
last year when some of us
on this show for instance said that it
seemed very likely that it escaped from
the lab
washington post put out headlines like
this quote tom cotton keeps repeating a
coronavirus conspiracy theory
that was already debunked that was the
headline in wapo
and then in early june they had to
change it they said quote tom cotton
keeps repeating a coronavirus fringe
theory that scientists have disputed
now i think the headlines should read
tom cotton says a thing that is
obviously true and is just common sense
to anybody with
two eyes in their heads that is not
being suppressed
by the liberal establishment yes
of course the lab had something to do
with this
and yet when we said this last year we
were called fringe nut misinformer
conspiracy theorists
who by the rules of the biden
administration and facebook
could very easily could have been
censored and taken offline and in some
cases were
they the biden administration people who
now make up the biden administration
were the misinformers the washington
post cnn the new york times
they were the misinformers here and they
continue to be the misinformers even
as their lives fall apart by the way the
who now is admitting
that the virus didn't come from the
wuhan wet markets the who
which has worked to help china cover up
what's going on
and in many ways works at the behest of
the chinese communist party
is now demanding audits be conducted of
chinese labs that were in the vicinity
of the first coveted cases
because they're admitting that the first
cluster of cases did not come
from the wet market in wuhan obviously
obviously but they control
the language and they control the means
of communication so they'll drip this
out when they want and they'll redefine
information as misinformation and
misinformation is credible information
and we can't do anything about it
we're still going to be kicked off of
the internet if we transgress what the
regime has set out for us
you're seeing this this is a little bit
of a tangent but you're seeing a similar
principle right now
there's a headline in the new york post
that shark advocates
i guess that's a category of people
picturing lawyers you know like
just lawyers for sharks you know all
right all right shark we've got
we're gonna make a really strong case
for you here's the case that they're
gonna make
they want to change the term shark
attack to the less incendiary
shark interaction it's an interaction
when you get your leg bit off by sure i
i myself prefer
underseas contingency operation that's i
think that would be the more technical
term but they want it to be a shark
interaction and it seems ridiculous and
it seems so crazy and
what no one's going to use this language
and people are going to use this
language
i bet they are if not on this issue than
on many others if we are now calling
bruce jenner she
they can change the language to mean
whatever they want and so is it any
surprise
is it any surprise that only six percent
of republicans according to a new gallup
poll
trust the tv news only 16
of all u.s citizens say they believe
what they see on television
no surprise at all because the real
information
is coming from the top and that and they
have the
gall and audacity to accuse the rest of
us
are pushing misinformation when we
question them i'm michael knowles the
michael knowles shall see tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
wall show we talk about the things that
matter
real issues that affect you your family
our country not just politics but
culture faith current events
all the fundamentals if they matter to
you come check out the show